[Musik]
man hätte ich sie echt aus als ältere
small bekommen oder so und dann herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem neuen
blog es ist wie spät ist es 36 früh
alles klar ich war die letzten drei tage
auf ein paar luca will festival
es war mega mega geil allerdings da wir
gekämpft haben und ich mega eine
pollenallergie habe naja wenn auch ein
bisschen angeschwollen es sollte aber
laut apothekerin in zwei tagen weg sein
dieses gefühl akku mit dem ich mein auge
kühlen sollen
da kannst du leute mit umbringen wollen
der plan voraus meine damen und herren
ich werde heute mit julia an die nordsee
fahren denn die nächsten zwei wochen
sollen in köln so immer mehr als 35 grad
sein
und da will man dann tatsächlich ungern
hier sterben deswegen haben wir gestern
schon übel stil gewaschen hier vorne
hängen noch voll viele sachen hier
hängen noch voll viele t shirt und ich
gehe erstmal duschen gehen
die schuldfrage ist doch nicht das erste
mal das ich hier seit vier tagen wieder
den bart was ihre freunde als ich
wiederkam
du wirst mich gar nicht wer könnte man
spaß ich sah genauso aus wie sonst
notebooks gang normalerweise würde ich
jetzt aber sagen wir machen und geld
dafür allerdings ein bisschen zeit
stress haben schaffen wir das heute
nicht so ganz
weil ich mir jetzt erstmal auch eine
sonnenbrille kaufen muss man das auch
ein fenster kaputt gegangen
[Musik]
hat eine neue brille freunde wie findest
du die sehr gut ich mag meine brille und
jetzt machen wir erstmal noch was zu
essen
danke dass ich den löffel ab alter noch
frau ist ein paar sekunden später
gestoßen
[Musik]
rogers ausschaut hier sehen sie wie man
das gut ist beim friseur
wir fahren jetzt mit dem auto an die
nordsee und wir haben leider ein wenig
stress
[Applaus]
von da hinter unserem
erstmalig schnell reagieren wenn auge
ist halt immer noch ein bisschen kaputt
deswegen ist hier zum glück eine ab
heute die ist nur für seehunde
weingarten eine kleinigkeit was essen
also ich kann mich selbst nicht an guckt
mit diesem augenblick wenn wir jetzt
gleich ich ich muss erstmal
die auswahl des bauens das könnte eine
ameise wand stativ hoch logenplätze
inspiriert mich verhört wird die ameise
ist wieder runter geklettert freuen das
sehr gute kameraperspektive hey ich
wollte euch kurz zusammenfassen was
überhaupt heute alles so passiert ist
wir haben uns einfach gedacht köln
wettermann nächsten tage da will man
nicht in köln seien deswegen habe ich
nicht und ich spontan gedacht die orders
an die nordsee fahren
die fähre auf die insel wo regale sind
es geht um 18.15 schaffen bei easy so
von kallen 12 1 los natürlich sind wir
nicht gegen 12 oder 1 gefahren besonders
erst gegen halb drei und dann saßen im
auto haben wir sind ok wegen staus so
die zeit die immer weiter nach hinten
wir packen das nicht mit der fähre hey
anrufen bei seinem privattheater
flughafen fähre verpasst können wir uns
vielleicht mitnehmen ok super toll wäre
das fast 330 euro ok keine andere
möglichkeit weil alle hotels in der nähe
waren ausgebucht und wir mussten halt
irgendwie auf die insel kommen und ja
wir sind zieren jetzt gehen wir was
einkaufen freunde und danach werde ich
euch mal über den titel so ein bisschen
was erzählen
[Musik]
wir waren einkaufen um jetzt allerdings
auf den titel zu sprechen zu kommen
freunde genau vor einem jahr habe ich
dieses video hochgeladen mein herz war
so flimmern
es hat sich die ganze zeit so auf und ab
gegangen hat das herz gesehen wie es von
vorne nach hinten die ganze zeit die
ganze zeit das ging über eine stunde 1 2
stunden ich konnte danach nicht wieder
einschlafen ich hatte todesangst und
allerdings meine panikattacken also das
ist bei mir so war dass ich aufgrund von
relativ viel uni stress damals vor allem
eineinhalb jahren und dazu noch
praktikum stress und youtube stress und
dann wird man natürlich auch noch
irgendwie ist ein freunden was machen
was in einer gewissen form hält auch
stress ist dadurch wird hervorgerufen
dass in einer ruhephase die dann bei mir
an stand wo ich im urlaub war und quasi
keinen stress mehr hatte dass ich dort
über das herzrasen hatte
herzrhythmusstörungen ich hatte
schweißausbrüche alles mögliche und ich
dachte wirklich in dieser nacht wurde
das alles zum ersten mal auftrat dass
ich sterben werde
das sollen nicht übertrieben klingen
sondern es war halt wirklich so ich
fasse euch das ganze jetzt einfach noch
mal kurz zusammen was damals so passiert
ist und vorgefallen ist einem ich habe
euch das video nochmal unten in der
beschreibung verlinkt was ich damals
hochgeladen habe also da könnt ihr
nochmal genau alles detailliert anhören
allerdings bin ich halt dann damals zum
arzt gegangen und er meint mit dem herz
ist eigentlich alles in ordnung aber
wenn das selber auftreten sollte gebe
ich jetzt einfach mal in die beta
blocker mit und sind halt echt kranke
medikamente sowie die habe ich dann auch
ein bisschen genommen die beta blocker
als es noch mal aufgetreten ist nur
irgendwann ist mir dann aufgefallen ja
irgendwie bringt das alles gar nicht so
viel und dann habe ich mich noch mal ein
bisschen weiter informierten dann habe
ich halt herausgefunden dass und
panikattacken und was bei panikattacken
hilft ist halt mal mit anderen
sollten darüber redet und dass man sich
wirklich selbst ein redet ihr mit mir
ist nicht es ist nicht einfach nur
kopfsache im tutorial in weil ich mit
zwei freunden von mir und wir haben auch
jeden tag natürlich alkohol getrunken
gewarnt fiel am feiern wenig am schlafen
jetzt ist halt ein festival so das ist
einfach so und auf den small and war
alles super da heißt es dann wieder zu
hause war war es halt so dass ich quasi
wie das so ist das herzrasen hatte und
ich konnte nicht richtig atmen
ich habe überall hat es nicht geschafft
einzuschlafen weil immer kurz vorm
einschlafen habe ich so bin ich so
aufgestellt und eine herz weit über dem
rasen und in dieser nacht habe ich dann
halt dieses video hochgeladen was ich
euch zu beginn gerade kurz eingeblendet
habe und was ich sicher brach zusammen
gefasst habe und nach diesem video habe
ich halt wirklich erstmal verein zwei
monate überhaupt keinen tropfen alkohol
getrunken dann habe ich halt langsamer
wieder angefangen ein bisschen was zu
trinken also beispielsweise irgendwie
meine bachelor entlassfeier so klar dass
man dann irgendwie mit einem champagner
anstößt oder so da war halt mein studium
auch vorbei und ich hatte weniger stress
und ich habe mir auch selber gesagt okay
ich nehme mir täglich diese auszeit von
ein paar stunden wo ich einfach wirklich
nichts mache oder irgendein spiel spiele
auf jeden fall irgendwas was mich
überhaupt nicht stress natürlich ist es
noch so dass wenn dir jetzt irgendwie
zusammen auch irgendwie feiern waren und
dann halt irgendwo backwaren und dann am
nächsten morgen um 10 auf stehen fünf
stunden später also noch 15 schlaf
gehabt haben dann auch beim training
waren im gym oder so dass mein herz dann
schon wie ist das gefühl es ist jetzt
nicht mehr so allen elf mal schlägt ist
man sich hinterher schnell und dann ist
es mir mit dass soja sind aussetzer
haben dass man fast normal schlägt aber
dann auf einmal doppelt so langen pause
wieder auf jeden fall tritt das ganze
allerdings viel viel viel viel seltener
auf und auch einfach weil ich glaube ich
dieses video hochgeladen habe damals
weil ja
es bringt halt wirklich was so einfach
mit leuten darüber zu reden und nach
diesem video kamera viele leute und
freunde von mir an und 1 mio ich habe
das auch auf jeden fall wollte ich jetzt
hier heute nachdem ich das video
wirklich vor genau einem jahr
hochgeladen habe und ich weiß es ja auch
ein paar locker will
festival und das frank weise genauso
moment also wieder drei vier tage auf
dem festival wenig getan für alkohol
getrunken gefeiert
was weiß ich was danach hatte ich das
nur ganz leicht so dass mal wieder
gesagt ja ich habe auch schon gemerkt
dass du dass dein herz irgendwie so ein
bisschen komisch geflattert hat und
keine ahnung was aber ich hatte zum
beispiel nicht dieses und das hat mich
seit monaten nicht das sieht einfach
nachts aufgewacht bin oder bei während
das einschlafen so aufgewacht bin
schweißgebadet dass mein herz bei so
richtig gerast und ich denke okay jetzt
ein herzinfarkt und mein herz explodiert
und die sterne gerade und ist man halt
echt viele leute damals hinter dem video
juden kannst du nicht mal irgendwie so
ein update video machen wie das nicht
wenn jetzt verbessert hat weil wirklich
ein pickel mendig in der beschreibung
drauf schaut euch das video mal an oder
schaut euch zumindest mal die kommentare
an wir haben so viele leute geschrieben
ich habe das auch und wie hast du das
jetzt in den griff bekommen ist jetzt
besser geworden ich wollte nur mal ganz
kurz eben hier so ein update darüber
geben weil es halt jetzt wie gesagt
genau ein jahr her ist und ich jetzt
auch beim palucca will was genau so ist
wie das talent jetzt und ist mir jetzt
24 besser geht weil ich weiß was ich
habe und weil ich mit leuten darüber
geredet habe und ich weiß auch dass ich
kein rad bin und unter dem video kam auf
mega viele leute an die meinten ich
hätte das ist falsch dargestellt und
keine ahnung was hast du dargestellt wie
ich es selbst an mir feststellen konnte
wie ich selbst war sie miterleben konnte
und was bei mir geholfen hat und
deswegen ja das kann ich für für alle
stimmen was ich gott sage aber so kriege
ich das bei mir so ein bisschen angriff
einfach dass ich meine atmung anpasst
ich habe mit sondern wie heißt dieser
apps box brief runtergeladen das
manchmal sie irgendwie sechs sekunden
einatmen sechs sekunden l 66 sekunden
hält
da gibt's verschiedene art und weisen
mann soll
das einreden dass nichts passiert und ja
seitdem ich das quasi weiß habe ich das
ganze recht heftig gut im griff
allerdings fehlt ihr schon das ist hier
schon ein bisschen dunkler wird von der
mutter die zumindest überhaupt so eine
schöne will ich jetzt also diesem blog
ja heute auch beenden
mir war es wichtig dass das jetzt heute
noch mal so ein bisschen aufgreifen weil
es jetzt wirklich wie gesagt ein jahr
genau her ist dass ich diese
panikattacken situationen hochgeladen
habe und dass ich das sehr krass hatte
und jetzt noch mal so ganz das erste
revue passieren lasse also ja leute
können wenn die kommentare schreiben
ob ihr das ganze elend hat geht wirklich
aus euch hinaus so das beste ist
wirklich wenn man es halt darüber zu
reden
da bringt keine medikamente was gar
nichts ich hatte wirklich heftige
medikamente dagegen genommen weil mir
ärzte gesagt haben dass es irgendwas mit
mehr herz ist obwohl es doch nichts war
allerdings beende ich jetzt auf dem
blogger dieser stelle an alle die sich
fragen was hinter hier mit meinem auge
somit hier los ist das war die letzten
tage krass angeschwollen wegen pollen
oder so dann die ersten korn oder keine
ahnung was also das hat jetzt nichts
irgendwie mit irgendeiner krankheit oder
keine ahnung was zu tun und ich sind
jetzt hier auf jeden fall erstmal eine
woche an der nordsee ein bisschen das
wetter genießen ein bisschen anstand
gehen das heißt den nächsten blogs
werden halt von hier kommen
und ja ich hoffe das war ich jetzt nicht
zu ernst dieser block quasi zum ende hin
aber ich wollte einfach noch mal darüber
reden weil viele halt meint und wie
sieht's aus und jeweils seit einem jahr
ist und weil ich jetzt auch wieder von
dem festival kommen und das wieder so
ein bisschen miterlebt habe aber auf
jeden fall viel schwächer muss auch mal
[Musik]